games are experiences then how you play
can be just as important as what you
play for too long players have had to
choose between the precision of a mouse
or the familiarity of a controller
between the power of a PC in the comfort
of the couch but why shouldn't you get
to have both the steam controller isn't
just a game pad it's a passport that
brings thousands of games previously
only playable with a keyboard and mouse
to the comfort of your couch using
one-to-one positioning the steam
controller can virtualize familiar
controls like a trackball a mouse or a
scroll wheel you can also effortlessly
type from the couch we've tossed out
hunting letters with a cursor and made
surfing the web as easy as texting your
friends PC gaming is all about options
and that's why you can customize
everything about your controller on a
game to game basis don't have time to
figure out the perfect layout on your
own turn to the Steam Community and
download the control scheme that's right
for you dive in and surf the web or hook
up multiple steam controllers and have
your friends over for a night of fun are
you looking to step up your competitive
game the dual stage triggers of the
steam controller have both an analog
pull and a digital switch the grip
buttons on the back I mean you never
have to take your thumbs off target
again and all of this is brought
together with real time haptic feedback
delivered by twin force reactors
bring your favorite games friends and
features to the living room with the
steam controller